last shift or malum I don't know if I
can I well I think Anthony your trailer
for the last shift has millions of views
combined yes yeah why do you think it's
so popular I think you know when I
sought out to make the last shift I
wanted to scare people like that was my
main and I had done
other you would call Thrillers in the
genre but I think last shift was my
first real horror film and and my
intention was I just want people to
watch this movie and be terrified that
was my goal so the plot was very simple
and I think over the years it got just
good W mouth and people were like this
is actually a scary movie you know it's
like it was it became kind of got a cult
following I think people are still
revisiting it now so it it it's kind of
one of those films when I grew up you
know you could go to the video store and
rent a movie you could tell your friends
like hey you've never seen this movie
you should watch this you know you get
excited when you get to share a movie
with someone they haven't seen last
shift still has that I think people can
even in today's day and age you can
still tell your friends oh you've never
seen last shift we should watch this
together you're going to have a blast
and I think that's why it's continued to
to have legs and plus I think you feel
something for the protagonist right away
when she's on the phone call I don't
want to give too much away but the
opening shots and you you want to go on
this ride for her you want to rout for
her yeah and I think that again that was
like so intentional of just like let's
throw people in right away cuz yes the
movie opens and and you're just
listening to this girl talk on the phone
to her mother you kind of creeping up
behind her and you're just in you're
immediately in her point of view it's
almost like you're playing a video game
she's the main character and you're just
over her shoulder right you're you're
reacting with her the entire movie I
think that really puts especially in in
in that genre in Thriller and
horror it puts you in the seat right it
really does when you're you're you're
not ahead of the the protagonist
you're not behind her you're just you're
with her the whole time and you're
learning we're not telling you a lot
about her you're learning about her
through her conversations with other
people and her and how she reacts to
things right and that she seems like she
she wants to do a good job as as evidenc
by her reading the manual and just kind
of being very the good student yeah I
won't give too much more away I know
it's on tub right now which is great
yeah it's on you can rent it on iTunes
itff too where did the idea for the last
shift come from it came from I had made
two other movies in Florida at the time
and IID got to know that sound crew very
well that we had worked with and I
thought that I could really
challenge them and collaborate with them
on something that was very sound driven
that was the main idea behind last shift
that started it was like how can I you
know how can Scott and I wrote that
Together Scott poy how can we tell a
story that is 50% audio and and to me
audio really creeps people out you know
you really get under their skin if you
can get into the the audio of the room
so we designed that movie to be very
contained and very driven by sound so
that's where it all started from and
then I think originally I had said hey
we should do this movie at a dispatch
office because that would be a lot of
communicating with on a dispatch with
dispatchers and and on the phone a lot
and it morphed in we found this location
before we wrote the script we're like
okay we have this great police station
that's decommissioned in Florida and
then we started to cater the script
around it and kind of morphed into what
L ship became and with the antagonist in
that
film I thought you know the Manson
family we knew kind of morph him what if
it was this cult and I was like well you
know Cults are scary but what if they
were ghosts you know the Manson family
were ghosts that would be even scarier
do you think if you hadn't found that
location it would have been a different
movie or you were planning to make that
movie regardless it probably would have
became a different movie because it's
not it was not the easiest thing to find
a decommissioned police station and I
don't think we wanted to fake it we
didn't want to cuz there's a lot of
unique things in a police station with
the holding cells and the offices and
and we we if we had found like a a fire
department or you know a fire station
that was decommissioned we probably
would have turned it into a different
movie I think that location had a lot to
do with what it became what's the
biggest difference between the last
shift and malum well budget size was the
first thing you know we made we made
last shift for a very small amount of
money uh and it was when we did it at
the time we had made two bigger budget
films in that
area and you know you when you make a
bigger budget film you give away a lot
of the rights when you're selling it and
things like that and we wanted to retain
as much of last shift as we could and so
that was my approach to that I and it
was also a challenge like what could we
do on such a small budget and retain a
lot more of the ownership of it
so and it ended up becoming my most
popular movie at the time and maybe
those restrictions is what made it all
that more creative between Scott and I
and the whole crew and keeping it
limited keeping the crew
limited uh so that was the first thing
budget right we had a much larger Budget
on malum to kind of go back and revisit
the story but also tell it in a
completely different way I I don't I see
them as two completely different movies
they have the
same basic premise you know if the if I
I was to throw someone an elevator pitch
they'd sound very similar but I never
felt like I was making the same movie
when I was making malum it just it felt
like a completely different
experience and again the location we
found a decommissioned police station in
Kentucky and it was it's like a hundred
times the size of the one we had in
Florida it's it was so much bigger and
it gave us so many more locations to
play with so I think just scope and
scale
is is the biggest thing between them and
then also the approach
of giving more to the characters you
know I said last shift was very sparse
on development in in malum we wanted to
create more of a mythology of both the
villains and the protagonists and let
people get to know the characters a lot
more just out of curiosity are there a
lot of like decommissioned government
buildings that you can find for uh
filming I don't know I we probably not
but we got lucky with you know they knew
because I think a lot of movies take the
approach of well we'll just find any
building that works you know let's get
where are we going to shoot you know you
kind of decide where you're going to
shoot and then you're like okay well
let's find a building that's going to
match it as close as possible and
talking with a welcome villain made
malum I said very early on hey we shot
the first one in a police station we
need to do that again for this film
because if that felt authentic this one
has to as well and if it's going to be a
bigger film we have to at least start
there so that was kind of
the they had some they had an investor
in Kentucky and and they put that out
early hey you know are there any empty
police stations in Kentucky and then it
just came back that there was a very
recently empty it was the city police
station so it was in the heart of
downtown uh
Louisville so we got lucky that way
because it's it's a massive building and
we were surrounded by a lot of
infrastructure and the new police
station wasn't that far away they just
happen to move somewhere else so it was
a cool
experience that we could work in a
facility that had so much to offer
including much larger facilities with
cells and holding facilities and things
like that what's your argument for the
last shift being better than malum I'm
pretty honest about my interpretation of
the movies because to me you know I'm
just one person every audience member is
going to have a different take on a
movie I think last shift is a scarier
film uh because it's
so intimate and
contained so if I and and the score is
much different it's approached in a very
different
way so if someone's looking to you know
sit at home alone and put on their
headphones or put on their stereo and
watch this movie in the dark last shift
is going to creep them out in a
different kind of way it's going to get
under their skin and it's you know it's
going to make you not want to sleep that
night malum is more of a Thrill Ride and
it's going to offer them a more visual
experience if people like special
effects special makeup effects if people
like to see more gruesome things things
and I'm not
saying yes it's a gorier film um but
it's a trippier film they're going to
see things with special makeup effects
they're going to see monsters they
haven't seen before and they're going to
be scared in that way and you're on a
journey that
is much more visceral in m so you may be
more tense watching M and you will
probably be much more invested in the
lead character who was also named Jess
Jessica Lauren in that film I think
that's where malum stands out and it's a
completely different experience than
than the previous film last shift did
you take into consideration you know the
changes I mean both of the films are
almost close to a decade apart and how
the world had changed so much in in so
many ways were there things that you
incorporated or you just really wanted
to stay close to the story and the
protagonist journey and not Infuse it
with anything that was going on in the
world when I you know started talking to
Scott about hey we we're thinking about
revisiting the story I said to him you
know police are looked at in a different
way now that was for sure part of it but
you know that the core of last shift was
the police station we knew we were
keeping that so we're just well now we
are 10 years later we're not going to
change it we're going to just deal with
with how things are because you know
controversy around police had heightened
a lot and that was something
that ining the characters Journey was
how we addressed it like we didn't want
to hammer anyone over the head with any
political things because we had great
police on the movie police training our
lead character our lead character and
our lead actors doing gun training with
police they we were filming at a police
station we worked with the Kentucky
police a lot so it was never meant to be
degrading to officers it's all meant to
be through the point of view of the lead
character
so that's how we addressed it in writing
if people were going
to
mirror what the news was saying about
police it was going to be how would that
affect her cuz she loves police her
father's a police officer she has a very
high regard for officers
and for the status of the badge going
in so when you take that
approach the outside forces are the ones
that are going to try to manipulate that
and tear that down tear that belief down
or make her feel like her father was a
bad person so it was all and the you
know Jessica Sula who played the
character she did not want to get into
that she was
like I don't care about this stuff I
don't care like how the world if if
there's if police are a hot button thing
right now she's like I don't care I just
want to I'm playing this character and
the same approach I had it's like how do
the other characters in the film deal
with that around her if you had to give
us your final verdict which movie's
better in your
opinion
watch last shifter malum I don't know if
I can I well I think you know I think
Mal's a better film because I think it's
I'm a better director now and therefore
I think it became a better film because
of it it's 10 years later I've directed
several films in between malum is a more
sophisticated picture and it it is the
movie we sought out to make entirely you
know we didn't have to compromise on it
you know well every movie you have to
make compromises but you know we're
we're we're not making a $30 million
movie so you know there's always
restraints with budget but as a
filmmaker I just was more confident in
the story I was telling and working with
the actors I think I think we have some
phenomenal performances in mum that you
know I'm very proud
of